gianna Brian Vanessa Bryant continues to
mourn her 13 year old daughter Gianna
Vanessa's second oldest child died in a
helicopter crash on January 26th
alongside her dad Vanessa's husband of
18 years Kobe Bryant and seven other
victims on Wednesday Vanessa shared this
pic of Gianna's Jersey retirement
ceremony featuring balloons and a giant
arrangement of roses shaped like the
number two which was her mamba academy
jersey number she captioned the shot
quote my Gianna god I miss you I've been
so lucky to have woken up to see your
gorgeous face an amazing smile for 13
years wish it would have been until my
last breath mommy loves you to the moon
and back infinity plus one the 37 year
old also shared a series of videos from
the ceremony including a few of the
heartfelt speeches from her coaches
classmates and teachers who spoke at the
emotional event held at Harbor Day
School in Corona del Mar California and
helped us find a way to win she did just
that she Willis to the finals and got
her teammates very high level she was a
hard-ass all of his
in her competitive nature was infectious
that's Gianna's coach who also shared a
story about how a few weeks ago the
school's eighth grade boys team was
playing against a rival school and
Gianna asked to compete on their team to
help them win Gigi could have played
with those boys she could help them win
some games
she was definitely able to hold her own
Gigi won was one of the fiercest
competitors ever seen Vanessa also
shared the moving moment when the school
retired her Jersey she captioned the
clip quote my Gigi I love you I miss you
you've taught us all that no act of
kindness is ever too small mommy is
still and will always be so proud of you
mamacita
Vanessa's heartbreaking tribute comes
just hours after she shared a pic of
Kobe writing my best friend the best
daddy
miss you so much handsome sweet funny
silly loving husband Gigi's a basketball
player she is that she's in it does she
have that inner focus like her daddy
yeah she's she just don't go killer out
there yeah at both ends of the floor and
she plays defense as well as offense man
she competes Vanessa first broke her
silence on the tragic deaths of Kobe and
Gianna last week writing on Instagram in
part quote there aren't enough words to
describe our pain right now but we wake
up each day trying to keep pushing
because Kobe and our baby girl Gigi are
shining on us to light the way our
responsibility is to always inspire and
try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned and share those
with the next generation so that they
can start their journey with the leggo
and it seems like she is doing what she
can to keep Kobe and Gianna's memories
alive on Monday Ichi learned that
Vanessa personally requested that some
mementos left at the Staples Center by
fans of Kobe
be given to the Bryant family of course
you can count on et to bring you all the
latest on this story until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens see you soon
[Music]